by about high school I knew that I
wanted to do something in physics
I knew that MIT would be a great place
for that and I had heard about how
undergrads could do research
Michelle is extremely smart extremely
motivated one of the key things
undergraduates bring to the table is a
fresh perspective a willingness to
essentially try things that sometimes a
sort of a seasoned researcher you sort
of overlook you think you know what the
answers gonna be
you let hubris essentially take over and
you don't explore things that sometimes
undergraduates do and sometimes they hit
the jackpot so what is this what are we
looking at these are the plots of the
average flux with respect to frequency
and just for your convenience I what
I've been doing is to model one
particular type of a new class of
structures called photonic crystals what
is a photonic crystal well it's a
periodic structure with features where
the periodicity of the structure is on
the wavelength of light I am starting
what frequencies and wavelengths of
light are emitted the most when parts of
the crystal are excited here there are
two very distinct peaks where the energy
emitted is much higher for those ranges
of frequency
the importance of that work is that a
lot of these fluorescent molecules are
being used to do spectroscopy or to
monitor cells or microscopic and
nanoscopic objects this is essentially
your unit cell size in O lambda so for
example one might think of essentially
piggybacking one of these molecules in a
tumor cell and imaging essentially the
behavior of the tumor cell as a function
of time or as a function of space
I mean if it's Laurentian it seems
fairly straightforward right yeah
research is not limited to postdocs and
grad students undergrads can do it too
and often they contribute a very vital
role in some the research that goes on
and this is basically tangentially
important like the lightest system I was
an undergraduate here one of the reasons
I came to MIT was actually because of
the UROP program once you find what
you're really interested in it what you
want to do you can continue doing that
and that can eventually develop into
your graduate program I wouldn't be
where I am today actually if it weren't
for the Europe program